every day
it arrives
produced by the truckload donated to
this food bank in northwest london
and today the frontline in the battle
against poverty is also the frontline of
a cost of living crisis
this is our food hub
with inflation now at a 30-year high the
pressures on households are becoming
ever clearer
our queues are increasing just last week
we served 180 people outside our queue
we've seen that increase by 40 percent
have you got anything for me like meats
or
dinners
karen is among hundreds of people
reliant on the support of this place why
it comes back to the cost of living
food is going up in price
um gas and electricity the council tax
the rent i find it really hard to sleep
get nightmares
because because of those financial
pressures yeah we've gone without eating
we just had toast for dinner
yeah
sorry i'm getting a bit emotional
but only when you appear beneath the
surface of the inflation statistics do
you see just how widespread these price
rises are
what is inflation it's ultimately about
the rate at which the typical shopping
basket of goods and services is rising
in the past year and the striking thing
is just how fast they're rising bread up
by about four and a half percent
margarine up by 27
margarine uh apples up by about a fifth
beef and veal up by seven percent you
get the idea that's just food well it's
worth the same avocados have fallen in
price but take it all together and
you're talking about remarkable
increases in the cost of living
and that's before you consider things
like the wholesale gas price
its trajectory now even higher than the
last time the bank of england looked at
it says the governor started to go back
in the market pricing towards
where it was pre-coded
now it doesn't come off until next
middle of next year towards the tail end
of next year
so that is a big shift
that of course raises the prospect of
another hike in interest rates perhaps
as soon as next month
at this factory in the west midlands
where they turn steel into covers and
gratings it is metal prices which are
the big inflationary force
in a space of just under 18 months we've
seen the price of steel increased by
over 100
which obviously had significant
implications on our manufacturing costs
to our customers
these are just snapshots from across the
country which is seeing the resurgence
of something economists thought they
vanquished long ago
there will be more inflation to come
ed conway sky news